ich will meine Geschichte erzählen was
mit mir passiert ist damit alle wissen
was die Russen gemacht
haben wir treffen rostislav in einer
Einrichtung in Kiev hier leben Kinder
und Heranwachsende die von den Russen
verschleppt wurden rostislav ist
halbweise er war 16 als die Russen sein
Dorf in der Region chon
besetzten ichin
ich Wste noch nicht dass der Krieg
begonnen
hat Autos fuhren die Leute waren in
Panik in den Geschäften war alles
ausverkauft und am Abend haben die
Russen unsere Siedlung besetzt es gab
Explosionen schüs
[Musik]
vien mein dor
meineomter
ausgehten am nen Tag sind die Russen
gekommen und haben meine Mutter ins
Krankenhaus
eingewiesen sie hatte eine psychische
Krankheit von früher und ich blieb
allein zu
Hause vi Monate habe ich allein unter
der Besatzung
gelebt ich hatte wenig Geld kaum
essen
als die Russen verstanden haben dass ich
ganz allein war sind sie zu mir gekommen
mit Waffen und haben angefangen mich zu
beden Sie habenag dass ich nachers um
dort nach dem russischen Programm zu
lernen ich habe das abgelehnt und sie
haben gesagt entweder gehst du lernen
oder wir schicken dich in irgendein
Internat am nächsten Tag sind sie
gekommen und hab nachers
Gefahren sie haben mich dort in einem
Wohnheim untergebracht sie haben mir
gesagt dass ich mir einen russischen
Pass zulegen
müsste aber ich habe gesagt dass ich mir
den nicht machen lassen
werde ich bin dort zwei Monate zur
Schule gegangen dann hat man mir gesagt
dass ich ins Camp fahren muss da ich
keine Verwandten hatte war es für mich
obligatorisch
am nächsten Tag kamen sie und haben mich
ins Lager nach eaturia gebracht das
Lager hatte den Namen drusba
Freundschaft dort sollten wir jeden Tag
mit der russischen Hymne Aufstehen wir
hätten die russische Flagge hen sollen
und russische Lieder singen
sollen oll be ersten ein Bericht
schreiben beim zweiten Mal hattest du
das Gespräch mit Herrn asachow
irgendeinem
Leiter beim dritten mal warst du in
einer
Arrestzelle ich war dort vierm insgesamt
15 Tage die Zelle ist ein Raum der 2 2 m
groß ist mit einem Bett einem Schrank
und einer Toilette und es gab einalk mit
Gitter sie haben mich beschimpft sie
haben gesagt dass es die Ukraine nicht
mehr gibt dasson und Odessa zu Russland
gehören alles wird gut steht auf R Handy
daran glaubt fest derricht V
ukrainischen Verein safe Ukrain
betrieben wird bekommt er auch
psychologische Betreuung er ist zusammen
mit anderen die ähnliches erlebt haben
das hilft sagt
er ich war in diesem Lager zwei Monate
lang und dann wurden wir in ein anderes
Lager gebracht dort war es ähnlich außer
dass dort irgendeine Kommission
hinkam ich war da auch eineinhalb Monate
lang dann hat man alle Studenten die da
waren versammelt und uns wurde gesagt
dass wir nach Kersch fahren sollten um
dort zu
studieren man hat uns nicht gefragt
welchen Beruf wir erlernen
wollen man hat uns einfach gesagt dass
wir morgen unsere Sachen packen sollten
und losfahren das war
alles wir sind in der technischen
Seefahrtschule in KCH gelandet
wir kamen dort an wurden im
Studentenwohnheim untergebracht und uns
wurde gesagt dass wir uns einen
russischen Pass machen lassen
sollten dann bekämen wir eine eigene
Wohnung und 100 000
Rubel
[Musik]
okay aber ich habe das abgelehnt sie
haben mir eine russische Geburtsurkunde
gemacht am nächsten Tag habe ich die
zerrissen dann haben sie noch eine
Urkunde gemacht aber die haben sie mir
nicht mehr
gegeben und sie haben mir auch meine
ukrainische geburtskunde
weggenommen
dann hat die Mutter meines Freundes von
der Stiftung save Ukraine
erfahren und hat sich auf den Weg
gemacht um uns
abzuholen sie hat sich eine Vollmacht
für einen weiteren jungen machen lassen
mein Vormund war sie
schon aber sie haben mich nicht gehen
lassen meine Freunde sind nach Hause
gefahren und ich bin
geblieben das war sehr
traurig
[Musik]
da das Wohnheim geschlossen wurde wurde
ich in ein Rehabilitationszentrum
geschickt wo ich zwei Monate geblieben
bin da durfte man kein Handy nutzen da
ließ man einen nicht rausgehen nur
zweimal pro Tag morgens und abends dort
hat man mir noch mal gesagt dass ich
einen russischen Pass machen lassen muss
und ich habe noch mal gesagt dass ich
den nicht machen lassen werde danach
wurde ich im Wohnheim untergebracht
blieb dort einen Monat lang und bin dann
von dort einfach
geflohen stolz zeigt rostislav den
fandungsaufruf den die Russen nach
seiner Flucht veröffentlicht haben wie
genau ihm das alles gelang darüber kann
er nicht
sprechen Weg in die Freiheit gelingt nur
wenigen und soll geheim bleiben mehr als
19000 Kinder und Jugendliche so schätzen
ukrainische Behörden werden nach wie vor
in Russland festgehalten roseslav
erinnert sich noch genau an den Moment
als er wieder ukrainischen Boden
betrat als ich über die Grenze ging und
ging und ging da dachte ich ist das
schon die
Ukraine und als ich auf Englisch das
Wort Ukraine sah da fing ich an zu
laufen vor lauter
Freude rostislav teilt sich sein Zimmer
mit einem Jungen der auch auf der Krim
war 20 Kinder sind in der Einrichtung
untergebracht rostisler fühlt sich wohl
in Kiev fotografiert macht Pläne für die
Zukunft ich möchte dass der Krieg zu
Ende ist und was meine Zukunft betrifft
so will ich weiter lernen ich will
entweder Programmierer oder Fotograf
werden
und irgendwann so sagt er will er auch
zurück in sein Dorf ob seine Mutter noch
lebt weiß er
nicht